the Palestinian movement is hostile to
individual liberty including and
especially the liberty of Palestinians
themselves Israel can no more defeat the
narrowly defined Palestinian movement
than the massive American military
machine could win any sort of military
victory in Iraq or Afghanistan
the Palestinian Authority moreover
incites its own people to commit
atrocities attacks against Israelis
knife attacks car rhymings and other
kinds of violent actions this is a
one-sided tale that my opponent is
telling of good Israelis and bad
Palestinians it's a necessary condition
to reach peace but the Palestinian
movement be defeated oftentimes one must
work with talk to and compromise with
certain nefarious actors now for the
main event
tonight's resolution reads to resolve
the israeli-palestinian conflict Israel
must first achieve defeat of the
Palestinian movement again for the
affirmative Ilan giorno Ilan please come
to the stage
arguing for the negative Danny Susan
Danny please come to the stage Jane
please close the voting good evening
Thank You Jean for inviting me Thank You
Danny for joining the debate and thank
you to the sponsors of the tides event
tonight's resolution presupposes a
detailed analysis of a hugely
complicated conflict that's the analysis
I offer in my book what justice demands
and here let me indicate one crucial
point to start with so much of the
debate and the discussion about the
israeli-palestinian conflict is bound up
in religious ethnic nationalist and
tribal premises and these get us nowhere
instead I suggest we need to adopt a
different approach we need to adopt a
secular individualist pro-freedom
perspective that's the framework that I
offer in my book and that's what I'll be
arguing from tonight and the reason for
this is I believe and I think you can
demonstrate objectively that individual
liberty is an objective moral ideal it
is true for all people in all places at
all times and I believe that freedom is
the standard by which we should evaluate
the adversaries in this conflict
so this individuals perspective that I'm
arguing for leads us to discard
collectivist and tribal premises and
that whole way of thinking and one of
the major steps in this way of thinking
is we need to recognize a major
distinction that I think gets blurred
and completely ignored by many people
there's a crucial difference between the
Palestinian community and the
Palestinian movement we have to be keep
these separate and distinct the
community is a group of individuals who
recognize themselves as part of
the Palestinian identity and they have
features of a culture and the
Palestinian movement is an ideological
political enterprise it has specific
goals and on an ideology and it claims
to speak for the Palestinian community
there is overlap between the two that's
definitely true but they can't be
treated as interchangeable they're not
they're distinct and we have to keep
them distinguished when we think about
this issue this debate hinges on a moral
evaluation of the adversaries so let's
ask does the Palestinian movement seek
freedom is it Pro human progress is a
concern with righting wrongs done to the
Palestinian community no no and no I
argue that the Palestinian movement is
hostile to individual liberty including
and especially the liberty of
Palestinians themselves and by contrast
I argue Israel is a region's only free
society it has flaws and moral failings
really serious ones and these need to be
addressed and reformed but none of these
warrant the Palestinian movements
aggression against it if you want to
understand this conflict I think it's
crucial to see that the Palestine
movement is an obstacle to peace it's a
fundamental barrier to progress in this
region let me stress this debate does
not hinge on the question of whether
individual Palestinians have grievances
they do some of them are legitimate
grievances and they need to be redressed
I argue this in my book for example are
cases of Israeli land expropriation or
cases where the Israeli police failed to
protect the land owners who are
Palestinians from Jewish religious
fundamentalists who attacked them that
is wrong it's a violation of the rule of
law and it has to be stopped but even
when you take all of these flaws and
failings into account they do not end is
particularly the grievances which I
regard as legitimate they do not justify
the militant goal of the Palestinian
movement which is to liquidate Israel
that's been true since the founding of
the major factions of this move
the Palestinian movement in a word has
exploited the people it claims to be
serving and protecting and righting
wrongs for in reality the Palestinian
movement is hostile to freedom and does
not care about righting wrongs done to
the people it claims to serve if you
look at what is the Palestinian movement
what is it composed of there are two
major wings the Palestinian Liberation
Organization or the PLO and Hamas the
Islamist wing both were founded with a
shared goal of bringing an end to Israel
as a society both are hostile to rights
and individual freedom and they try they
actively now in the present day not in
some future state that they are claiming
to seek right now they're trampling the
rights of their own people the PLO runs
the Palestinian Authority which is an
interim quasi state was supposed to be a
step toward full sovereignty and this is
mostly in the parts of the West Bank
it is a dictatorial authoritarian regime
the president of this organization this
entity is Mahmoud Abbas he his four-year
term as president ended about 10 years
ago and he is still in power and he's
not leaving he's going to appoint the
next prime minister it seems if you try
to live there you'll realize quickly
there is no freedom of speech there's no
freedom of association if you criticize
Abbas who is the dictator and in place
you may well be thrown in jail and God
help you if you're a Christian or if
you're gay under the Palestinian
Authority you will be hounded out if you
make it out alive and the Palestinian
Authority moreover incites its own
people to commit atrocities attacks
against Israelis knife attacks car
rhymings and other kinds of violent
actions and they celebrate the
perpetrators of these attacks as martyrs
to the cause and the Palestinian
Authority is led by the PLO should be we
should note this is what is considered
by many people as the moderate wing of
the Palestinian movement
so let's look at what people regard as
beyond the pale Hamas this is the
Islamist faction which runs Gaza and it
took over in a bloody coup in 2007 it
has injected Islamist ideas into the the
area where rules and it's conducted
summary executions in the street
Hamas is for rocket Wars against Israel
numerous times in 2008 2012 2014 and
there have been small skirmishes in
between there and of course they were
rocketed to rockets fired from Gaza last
week toward Tel Aviv and Hamas is
notorious for inciting its people to
commit suicide bombings and to celebrate
their acts of destruction of other
people this not only through the
mainstream press that Hamas controls but
through children's programming and
magazines
it is inculcating really perverse ideas
so when you look at the Palestinian
movement you realize that this is a
movement that is hostile to freedom that
does not care about the lives of the
people it governs and this is a movement
committed to liquidating a free society
basically free society in the region's
only free society in the Middle East
that's what I'll I'll suggest what I
argue in depth in my book now let me
stress I've argued that the Palestrina
move is hostile field let me argue let
me indicate some reasons to think that
it is not concerned with righting wrongs
actual wrongs done to Palestinians in
fact you can see by the way it's
governing that to the extent that has
control to the extent it has
self-government in Gaza and parts of the
West Bank the Palestinian movement has
inflicted its own forms of injustice
which I've mentioned there is no freedom
of speech under its control minorities
are persecuted horribly religious and
other minorities but worse than this to
the extent they have control over these
people of the Palestinian community the
Palestinian movement is not really
opposed to the kinds of crimes that it
accuses Israel of such as arbitrary
arrests censorship expropriation because
it itself is committing these a
crimes against its own people in my book
I mentioned one notable example which is
a Qatari businessman who came to the
Palestinian territories to open a bank
and help build out the what was
beginning to be a new state the
Palestinian Authority his bank and his
personal property were expropriated from
him by the Palestinian Authority in
broad daylight and there are many other
examples of this
now one other thing to note about the
Palestinian Authority at which again is
there is the wing within the Palestinian
movement that many people regard as deal
with and one Mahmoud Abbas is a sort of
is one of the people that is invited and
who visits the white house he has that
kind of diplomatic status under the
Palestinian Authority it is a crime to
sell land to Jews so this is a is
defined by people's race right there
ethnicity and it's the the kind of
punishment you can get and people
actually face this punishment is hard
labor for life and the maximum penalty
is death just keep that in mind so let
me turn now to look at Israel briefly
what I want to argue here is that if you
take seriously the value of human life
the value of human progress and a
freedom it's crucial to recognize a
stark moral difference and moral
inequality between Israel and the
Palestinian movement Israel stands out
as a basically free society one with
many flaws and moral failings and yet it
has freedom of speech it has religious
freedom intellectual freedom all
citizens regardless of race or creed
have the right to vote and be part of
the government now there are going to be
objections to Israel's moral standing
and I was anticipate some of them here
which is that is an ethnic national
state and that it's an apartheid state I
opposed the ethnic national elements of
Israel regard Israel as a combination of
individualist elements that are good and
that's what leads it to protect
individual rights and national ethnic
elements and religious elements which I
regard as a problem in a source of its
failings
we can talk about the apartheid claim
which deserves more attention in the
question period I invite you to ask me
about that I want to make the case for
why I think the the main barrier here to
reaching moving forward towards peace is
the Palestinian movement to the extent
that the current approach is being tried
the two-state solution it's led to
empowering the Palestinian movement it's
given them mini-state in effect in the
West Bank in Gaza which is a militant
regime that is hostile to the lives of
the people it controls and retrying the
the peace process that leads to a
two-state solution which is the
entrenched approach is going to lead to
the same kind of outcome it's not going
to change until the ideas that are
animating the Palestinian movement are
changed or it gives up its goal which is
what I advocate so the the approach
that's being tried so far has only made
the conflict worse more people have died
in violence since the signing of the
famous peace process deal under Bill
Clinton in xx in 1993 than did in the 25
years before that so this is a bad
attempt to suit to solve the problem
because I think it evades the character
of the adversaries and particularly the
Palestinian movement what I'm advocating
for instead what I'm suggesting is that
it's a necessary condition to reach
peace that the Palestinian movement be
defeated and this is because I think
what's happening is it's a protracted
war between two sides and Wars typically
end if we look at history when one side
gives up its goals when it puts down its
arms as hopeless and its goal is
unachievable and that's what I'm
suggesting needs to happen with the
Palestinian movement it needs to lose
heart it needs to give up its so-called
armed struggle and it's jihad and
through a combination of economic
political and military pressure the
infrastructure of the Palestine movement
in the West Bank and the Palestinian in
the Gaza Strip needs to be uprooted this
is a long-term process it's not going to
happen overnight and the crucial thing
that has to happen is a psychological or
a my
shift people need to the followers of
the Palestinian movement the leaders of
the Palestine moon need to abandon their
goal of liquidating Israel and creating
a society that is an authoritarian one
which is what they've been acting on all
this time and a major thing that can be
done from outside the conflict is that
all of us in this room all of us who
have influenced and particularly the
governments that here in the in the US
and in Canada and Europe need to with
withdraw their moral endorsement of the
idea that the Palestinian state is a
goal to be achieved because what we've
seen when it's materialized even to a
small degree is that it is hostile to
freedom and it is a militant regime that
is hot that seeks to undermine Israel
withdrawing that moral sanction and the
financial support that makes it possible
I think is critical to reaching the
point at which the Palestinian movement
feels defeated and gives up its goal
thank you very much Jenny surgeon for
the negative thank you my opponent has
undoubtedly laid out a passionate
detailed defense of Israeli policy over
the last half-century
he's also highlighted the very worst
aspects of what he dubs the Palestinian
movement where his remarks merely in an
unopposed introduction to this rather
complex topic the very simplicity of the
model would likely be persuasive
unfortunately as a veteran of two wars
in the greater Middle East and a budding
scholar of Israel Palestine I found
matters in this region far more nuanced
and thorny than all that it is for this
reason that I must oppose this
resolution tonight along with the black
and white thinking that informs it's
very framework I cannot promise you any
neat models nor any simple reassuring
solutions this intractable conflict
rather I hope to present a middling
approach to conflict resolution that
accepts as genuine the fears for Israeli
security but does not dismiss the plight
of the Palestinians outright mine is a
path of empathy and an attempt at
even-handedness for one-sided solutions
such as my opponent is crafted here
tonight will never bring peace to the
Holy Land that said the
israeli-palestinian crisis as many of us
know is a veritable third rail in
American political discourse so it may
be necessary for me to start with a few
disclaimers I speak as someone who is
not anti-semitic who opposes
anti-semitism in all the ugly forms it
takes and who believes the Israeli state
has a right to exist now that that's out
of the way I have to address the
controversial caveat Palestinians for
both moral and strategic reasons also
deserve state sovereignty and equivalent
civil rights and that should be the
stated position of libertarians all real
small see conservatives and my debate
opponent tonight Israel is neither saint
nor Satan neither is Palestine these are
two fluid societies that shift with
domestic and international winds the two
sides do not operate in a mannequin
world of good evil duality no matter how
much some of us would like them to in
that vein I shall oppose tonight's
resolution on the basis of three major
arguments first I reject as deceptive
the very term Palestinian movement
especially as mr. Giorno has
pejoratively defined in this movement is
no single thing and it's certainly not
nearly as simple or as evil Islamist
jihadi as the labels that my opponent
refers second I shall demonstrate that
the vast majority of Palestinian
organizations even Hamas can and should
be dealt with as potential partners in
negotiations indeed despite all the
blood spilt in recent years both Fatah
and Hamas are more willing than ever
before to make peace along the pre-1967
borders accept the two-state solution
and at least tacitly recognized Israel's
right to exist further I'll indicate
that it's often been Israel especially
under its contemporary right-wing
government that has provoked Hamas
broken truces and otherwise sought to
undermine the very existence
a popular democratically elected
Palestinian movement and finally I'll
argue that peace necessitates not a
fantastical notion of quote defeat of
the Palestinian movement which is
neither plausible nor grounded in
fairness rather what peace does require
is the isolation and common condemnation
of most terroristic elements of
Palestinian resistance but it demands
that we recognize and condemn Israeli
policies that also hinder conflict
resolution indeed in some cases making
peace impossible and that's what's
missing from my opponents opening
remarks the notion that Israel has a
role to play in reforming you see in the
way it's been laid out the Palestinians
are evil their movement at least their
leaders are all evil they can't be dealt
with and I reject that so finally I'll
argue that peace necessitates that any
solution in the Holy Land will not be
forthcoming unless the Israeli
government or hopefully a successor
administration reverses course in its
militarization an escalation of the
occupation regime and opens its mind and
hearts authentic negotiation with all
components of the multi-faceted
Palestinian movement so let us begin by
first assertion the resolutions
problematic definition of the
Palestinian movement I mean take a
moment to read to actually read the
resolution tonight that staggering
sentence that my opponent has affirms
I'm gonna break down three main parts of
it first off it's clear from the
resolution and for my opponents remarks
that he places Israel and Israelis at
the center of this model to him Israel
represents everything good in the world
juxtaposed with all the evil Arab states
of the region Israel and Israelis can do
no wrong this is problematic not only
because there are good people and good
faith movements in the Middle East I've
met many of them but because he lets
Israel off the hook for its own flawed
policies human rights abuses and
sometimes undemocratic tendencies in the
territories educated Israelis should
seek to improve their own society just
as Americans should it doesn't make you
an American or unpatriotic it's a
critique American foreign policy I will
say the same applies to Israel but
you'll hear very little of that tonight
this is a one-sided tale that my
opponent is telling of good Israelis and
bad Palestinians or
really movements and bad Palestinian
movements indeed yolk white you'll hear
quite little of the somehow absent
Palestinians from my opponent tonight
the Palestinians are almost the elephant
in the room that no one dare speak of
then there's the term defeat I must say
that as a combat soldier and officer
having conducted fruitless
counterinsurgency in Iraq and
Afghanistan which is remarkably similar
to duty in the West Bank in Gaza in fact
we study it the very term quote defeat
has come to seem rather absurd highly
unrealistic how can one people
how can one a defeat of people's
movement can one even win a true
counterinsurgency I'm quite doubtful and
so are most military historians but
that's precisely the assumption of this
resolution that Israel can and should
defeat the Palestinians this ladies and
gentlemen is fantasy it's it's wishful
thinking at best
lastly we return to the problematic
phrase Palestinian movement my opponent
believes that today's Palestinian
movement is the enemy an entity worthy
only of destruction I think that when he
looks at Palestine and Palestinians and
their organizations what he sees is Isis
that Palestinian equals Islamofascist
jihadism but Palestinians ok are little
more than terrorists in this telling and
that's just not accurate beyond being
wildly inaccurate it's a very very
dangerous conception it leads to a lack
of empathy for a lack of concern with
civilian lives a demonstrable fact is
this the vast majority of Palestinians
like the vast majority of Muslims are
not civilian slaughtering terrorists
Palestinians are a manifold diverse
people in fact they're the most highly
educated Arab people on the planet yes
there are monsters among them but this
is a small fraction of a vigorous and
beautiful whole so the crux of this
first argument is that the very
framework the very language and
construction of the resolution is poorly
defined factually inaccurate
unachievable and one-sided so much so
that on this point alone one should vote
down the resolution nevertheless let us
turn to my second major argument that
the vast majority of Palestinian
organizations even Hamas can and should
be dealt with as potential partners in
negotiation
service in America's never-ending post
9/11 wars has taught me that sometimes
oftentimes one must work with talk to
and compromise with certain nefarious
actors the US military tried quote
defeating Sunni Islam o nationalism in
western Iraq for four full years with
little or no success to the tune of
2,000 dead soldiers only went forward
thinking Colonels and a willing General
David Petraeus began talking to the
Sunni tribesmen and dividing them from
the most extreme elements of the
insurgency did the US Army achieve a
drop in violence this mind you was a
very hard pill for us to swallow in fact
many of our new partners in the Sunni
tribes had literal American blood on
their hands still there was no
alternative course with any hope to
lower violence ultimately protect US
soldiers and bring a semblance of peace
than to work with the Muslims of the
region work with the Sunni Islamists in
much the same way Israel must deal with
any Palestinian individual or
organization that is ready to accept a
long-term truce and a two-state solution
why because there is no other path to
peace none isolating Fatah or even Hamas
will alienate perhaps three-quarters of
the Palestinian people the notion that
upon the defeat of Hamas is leadership
or [ __ ] leadership the Palestinians
are just going to lay down okay and give
up and form some sort of new version of
themselves one that looks like an
Israeli just zipped up inside of them is
fantasy to keep on this path will freeze
any movement towards peace increased
violence and birth and I promise you
birth a generation far more radical than
the past Palestinian generation even
Hamas the unit dimensional villain of
mr. journos movement is a far more
complex and evolving movement than he
gives them credit for though it formed
as an Islamist response to twenty years
of Israeli occupation in 1987 though at
times after 1994 it engaged in suicide
attacks on Israeli civilians and though
it's early charter denied the right of
Israel to exist even Hamas has changed
and has come a long way in reality the
Hamas of 2019 is not the Hamas of 1987
and the organization can be dealt
with rather than quote defeated indeed
it has often been Israel that broke
truces and provoked Hamas such as in the
2004 Israeli assassination of Hamas
founder Sheikh Ahmed Yassin a
quadriplegic in a wheelchair this
targeted killing came on the heels of
Yasin having stated listen to this
Hamas could accept a Palestinian state
in the West Bank and Gaza Strip
furthermore that leader had also offered
a long-term truce in exchange for an
Israeli withdrawal from the occupied
territories this was significant shift
in Hamas policy that should have been
capitalized on instead Israel turned to
violence refusing then as it refuses now
to deal with and compromise with Hamas
what's more in 2006 Hamas published a
manifesto that lacked any reference to
the old goal of eliminating Israel
another positive change in the direction
of negotiation instead both the US and
Israel punished Hamas and by extension
the majority of Palestinian people who
voted for them in the Gaza Strip both
imposed sanctions and withheld
much-needed funding the New York Times
certainly not known for any anti Israeli
bias concluded that this was all part of
the plan quote to destabilize the
palestinian government so that newly
elected Hamas officials will fail and
elections will be called again this
sounds a lot like a coup except the coup
rather than being Hamas taking over
appears to be Israel in the United
States overturning a democratically
sanctioned election the bottom line is
that by associating the Palestinian
movement with the dictatorial nature of
secular Arab states and the violence of
Islamic extremism
my opponent denies the legitimacy of the
Palestinian struggle I reject the
simplicity and the factuality of that
assumption I'll now turn to my third and
final argument that Israel has its own
flawed policies I'm gonna flip the
resolution here and assert that aspects
not everything about Israel but aspects
of the Israeli movement must be reversed
before true peace is possible
among others these are one a perennial
military occupation of the West Bank in
Gaza to an illegal settlements regime
which is a colonization of the West Bank
3 a brutal blockade of the Gaza Strip
and for an unacceptably disproportionate
lack of concern for Palestinian civilian
casualties now there's no time for
history lesson I have maybe three four
minutes left but let me briefly address
these grievances first it is an
indisputable fact that the founding of
Israel in 1948 and the expansion of
Israel after the 1967 war created
millions of displaced Palestinian
refugees now am I saying this does not
mean that Israel must give it all back
that's unrealistic or cease to exist
that would be a genocide but rather it
recognizes the genuine suffering and
grievance of the Palestinian people that
there are two sides in this argument
mine is the side that says there are
guilty parties on both sides but there
are those we can work with on both sides
but you don't have to take my word for
it consider a 1969 interview with the
Israeli defense minister and national
hero Moshe Dayan where he admitted we
came to this country which was already
populated by Arabs and we are
establishing a Hebrew that is a Jewish
state here Jewish villages were built in
place of Arab villages you do not even
know the name of these villages and I do
not blame you because the geography
looks no longer exist not only do the
books not exist but the Arab villages
are not there either this is the one
place there is not one place built in
this country that did not have a former
Arab population then there's the
settlements regime the bottom line is
this until Israel dismantles its
settlements and returns that's land to
the rightful Palestinian ownership then
it is in violation of international law
and impeding the peace the idea that the
Palestinians are going to lay down and
accept any sort of solution while
massive massive numbers of Israeli
citizens upwards of 500,000 are living
in these settlements is it's fantasy I
can tell you these people are not going
to quit that's not how insurgencies ends
historically the brutal blockade of Gaza
is is it enormous ly cruel in fact to
demonstrate the cruelty and
premeditation of this blockade let us
consider that a prominent Israeli
governing official actually took to
literally calculating the number of
calories a person in Gaza needed lest
there be an outright famine someone one
of the aides to Prime Minister Ariel
Sharon reportedly joked that
because they voted the wrong way for
Hamas Palestinians would undergo
something like an appointment with the
doctor they will get a lot thinner but
they won't die let me conclude my
opening remarks in a rather sullen way I
would be remiss if I did not recognize
the historic crimes perpetrated against
Jews and of the worst crime in world
history the Holocaust for those reasons
among those reasons I believe Israel as
the right to exist and to be secured but
here's what I also believe there is a
second side to this conflict there are
Palestinians with genuine grievances
with leaders who can be negotiated with
and should be negotiate with they can
not be defeated nor should they be
if there's any sense of equity and
fairness Thank You United for the
rebuttal the Palestinian movement I said
just needs to be distinguished from the
Palestinian people and I guess that
didn't really sink in so let me amplify
that point there is no question that
there are Palestinians who have suffered
wrongs and I think they need to have
those wrongs redressed but let me focus
on the claim that the Palestinian
leadership in the movement because that
seems to be the crux of your argument
Palestine movement is not monolithic I
did not say that it was uniform I said
there are two major wings and it's
correct to equate it with the Islamist
movement but it's not the same as Isis
the Islamist movement is rather large it
includes both Saudi Arabia and Iran
which are conflicted countries and Isis
which both of them dislike the
Palestinian movement originated
primarily as an ethnic nationalist
movement and then it morphed over many
years into what is now primarily a
religious Islamist movement and you can
see that this is documented in the rise
of religiosity within the territories
and it's reflected in the rising 14
of Hamas now it is important to
recognize what Hamas is goals are and
what they remain so it is certainly true
that Hamas has issued member of
documents and manifestos and the most
recent one was not turning 2006 was
actually 2017 I believe where it issued
a policy statement and this was read as
Hamas is moderating now I will come I
will concede Hamas has changed its
position in tactical ways for example it
joined the elections in 2006 and which
it won by a landslide these are the
tactical maneuvers that it has done and
the most recent one in 2017 was to
insulate itself from the stench of the
Muslim Brotherhood which was in very ill
repute in Egypt Egypt being on the
border of Gaza and from Qatar which does
not like the Muslim Brotherhood and once
and that Hamas wants to be funded by
Hamas I think retains its goal it has
not disavowed its goal of liquidating
Israel none of those documents do that
when you read them closely what it does
is it presents itself in terms that are
meant to how shall I put it to gall and
fool people into thinking that Hamas is
somehow d-level with I don't think
that's true and I think the principle
that you can deal with anyone this is a
very common principle in diplomacy it's
false you cannot it's not true that you
can make a deal with anyone and that
there are factions within Hamas that are
better to the point where you can deal
with them that's just not valid and you
can see the evidence for that when the
piates because we had the same argument
about the Palestinian Liberation
Organization changing its position and
accepting Israel and it went through a
number of Hoops to do that and prove
itself in 1988 that actually went
exactly as you how one would expect it
was a lie and the same thing happened in
1993 when Arafat stood on the stage with
Bill Clinton and Robin that again was a
lie it didn't the Palestinian movement
did not then and has not since
repudiated its goal even if in tactical
ways it is moderated its positions to
seem more appealing
and and to lure people back to the
negotiating table what happened when
this was taken on faith is that the
Palestinian movement was given a
quasi-state in the Palestinian Authority
which enabled it with money and arms to
carry out what was then called the
Second Intifada or rather in war against
Israel by suicide bombers and other
kinds of attacks that was one of the
most lethal outbreaks of violence that
has been in this conflict
let me mention you raised some of the
historical points which I invite people
in the audience to raise in the question
pyramid we can have more discussion of
it I think it's important to recognize
that in fact the grievances are treated
as well they're obviously wrong Rayo
there's real wrongs here I think it's I
am in favor of nuance and otherwise took
me a book to argue my point I think
you're missing some of those including
with the settlement which I think cannot
be treated as a uniform phenomenon and
I'm certainly not in favor of Israeli
policy I'm not here to defend it I'm
arguing for Israel's position as a free
society to the extent it's free and for
as long as it's free and for long as
it's carrying out policies that are
consonant with that I do not support I
certainly don't support all the policies
that is enacting and I oppose many of
them as you'll find in my book thank you
[Applause]
thank you so I have about five minutes
to address some of the rebuttals from
the last two statements from my opponent
who is very well informed and has
written an excellent book on the topic I
have one question why is it and this is
really hypothetical Israel's state to
give to the Palestinians the whole
framing seems problematic it seems that
if Israel has a right to exist there's a
right and equivalent right for Palestine
to exist yet in this telling it is
Israel that somehow has the ability the
right even to grant but what's been
called a quasi-state to the Palestinians
which is little more than an open-air
prison in many ways which is little more
than a collaboration as the regime in
many ways my opponent spoke in his early
remarks about a pro freedom perspective
and I agree that that should be the
framework but what about the life and
situation of actual living breathing
Palestinians in Gaza today who lacks
civil rights who lack the basic freedoms
of even Arabs within Israel who already
don't have the same rights as Jews
within Israel but who live under
military occupation 50 years after the
1967 war in defiance of every single
ruling of any international court or
international organization now perhaps a
hundred and eighty countries in the
world are all just anti-semitic and only
Israel in the United States are correct
or maybe they're something to these
grievances for not just Palestinian
people but for their movement which
represents them I agree with my opponent
that this should have hinge on the moral
interpretation but a moral
interpretation would again make one
wonder why there are no civil and
political rights and no Palestinian
state sovereignty my opponent also says
that the Palestinian movement is an
obstacle to peace but what about Israeli
obstacles except for just a vague notion
of Israel's not perfect from my opponent
there's no list of what the Israeli
obstacles to peace are why is there
nothing about this I'd argue the silence
on this issue is more telling than
anything my opponent says I think it's a
fallacy that the Palestinian movement is
dedicated the destruction of Israel in
1993 actually before then the PLO did
accept the right of Israel to exist did
accept the two-state solution even Hamas
while didn't change its full original
document has made it clear that it's
willing to accept the two-state solution
from its highest leadership levels and
that it will accept the long-term truce
the truth of the matter is Israel never
made steps towards the final settlement
that 1993's Oslo was supposed to create
if the Palestinian movement is so
harmful to Palestinians why did they
vote it in why did so many of them turn
to Hamas could it be that part of it was
frustration with the lack of progress
towards a Palestinian state could it be
the intransigence of Israel in many
cases not every time not every
Palestinian leader is a saint not every
Israeli leader is a villain but the
reality is there are two sides to this
story there are two sides to this
situation the question for me is what if
Palestinians vote the wrong way it
appears you either have to believe in
democracy or not democracy appears okay
for Israelis because we can we're happy
with the way they vote but what about
when the Palestinians democratically
elect Tomas into government who then has
the right to determine that Hamas cannot
be dealt with
like I said in Iraq and Afghanistan we
dealt with people who literally had the
blood of our soldiers on our hands and
it worked and we didn't like it one bit
I still don't but what I knew is that
we're never gonna defeat the Iraqi
nationalist movement in Iraq we're never
gonna defeat militarily the Taliban in
Afghanistan
good luck the Soviets tried we've been
trying
Fulks spoilered it's not it's not gonna
happen they're not going to just give up
and roll over this is not going to
happen it is a historical from a
military history standpoint putting down
their arms is not how movements end
compromise and politicization of
movements is how they ends so these
steps of Hamas towards negotiation are
the signs of possibility for peace take
the Irish Republican Army
thirty years of being told that the IRA
will never ever settle for peace they
didn't just lay down their arms they
were brought into the movement
so much so that today members of
parliament in Britain used to be IRA
brigade commanders in Northern Ireland
but the British swallowed their pride
and realized they had to deal with
people who had blood on their hands
otherwise they would fight this war for
another eleven hundred years and that's
the reality do the Palestinians have
some sort of biological predilection for
evil I think not perhaps there is a
historic injustice and some role the
Israelis are playing in this I think
that the silence on the issue of Israeli
perpetuation of violence and even rights
abuses is instructive thank you thanks
to you both and we go to the Q&A a part
of the question a part of the evening
I'm a tech moderators prerogative to ask
a couple questions first - Danny sirs
and then because you can come in as well
even you have you've affirmed your own
support of Israel's right to exist and
Ilan was saying that most recently Hamas
seems to be ambiguous about that you say
that in their masses for basic document
they still do they deny Israel's right
to exist
well my particular question most sharply
is what is your best evidence that Hamas
has affirmative Lee stated as you have
stated it is realized the right to exist
[Music]
okay that's a great question well for
positive evidence I like evidence almost
attest expen three rewards in Gaza since
2008 Operation Cast Lead was 2008 there
was another war in 2012 and another in
2014 the US State Department actually
recognized as well as an international
terrorist analysis organization in
Israel that got the the Hamas
fighters actually showed a fair amount
of acceptance of the long-term truce and
it was actually Israel that broke the
truce in each of those cases so in all
three cases Israel actually conducted
raids into Gaza broke the truce at which
point Rockets were then fired very
inaccurately into Israel and then of
course the response was overwhelming
Palestinian casualties thirteen hundred
and seventy one in Operation Cast Lead
of which seven hundred and seventy two
were civilians and some 320 were
civilians or were children so I think
what we can do is look at how Hamas acts
rather than what's in their founding
document Hamas is dealing with radicals
and their own ranks they're dealing with
moderates their own ranks and they're
dealing with the folks who want to work
with Israel who want to work with the
Palestinian Authority so what I think
we're seeing is Hamas is waging a battle
because it's a fluid organization to
maintain the truces and what we know is
Hamas is capable of maintaining a
long-term truce it is as capable of
holding a long-term truce as Israel
which at this point is enough from my
perspective to negotiate with doesn't
mean we have to fall in love with the
mosque we have to deal with their
reality that be win elections and
they're going to have to be dealt with
on some level you want to come in
dealing to that answer okay the question
to you Ilan and then I'm gonna give it
over to either view or to the audience
you said a couple of times that there
are legitimate Palestinian grievances
that should be redressed could you
elaborate on those grievances that
should be specifically redressed sure
can I be yes but I mean I mentioned two
other and I think they're important
because they speak to the moral
framework that I'm bringing one of the
worst things that's happening in Israel
right now is that Jewish fundamentalists
are trying to illegally settle land and
I and I think that is wrong it violates
the law in Israel it's a violation of
the rule of law and one of the ways they
do this is they basically squat I mean
in English law squatting is when you
just take over someone's property and
you sit there until they
you exclude them they do this and then
they expect the government to come
protect them and they have accomplices
within the within various levels of
government I think this is wrong
it essentially steals land that does not
belong to the belong to the Palestinians
and Israeli of the Israeli government as
removed many of these illegal outposts
and settlements and undal them by force
and I think that's one an example where
there's real wrongs done to Palestinians
right now not in history living
breathing people now who are suffering
another kind of example that happens is
not only those kinds of squatting
situations but attacks on Palestinian or
chodes
that are carried out again often by a
religious fundamentalist Jews and they
the point of that is you destroy
someone's olive grove or their orchards
and you basically ruin their farm and
and that's destroying their property and
they should be the perpetrators of those
crimes have to be stopped and put in
jail and punished in a full extent of
the law
I think there are so one of the things I
would say about grievances is that Danny
mentioned the refugee problem I think
red the refugee problem is probably the
thorniest one and that's one where I
think it's really complicated to
untangle because part of the problem
which Danny hasn't really brought out in
his historical snapshot is that what led
to that war was the initiation of war by
neighboring Arab states in 1948 and that
the culpability for that has been evaded
over time and that their attempts to
resettle those refugees and attempt to
reduce the number and to compensate them
they were all pushed aside and refugees
that are settled in Lebanon for example
are in a situation that is worse than
Gaza if you want a place with a wall
around it and they can't bring in cement
and they can't become citizens go to
look at Lebanon that's that is a real
crime and I've heard nothing about the
crimes against the Palestinians done by
our Arab regimes that refuse to give
them any kind of succor or citizenship
or even to get a job if you're in
Lebanon so I think there are real
grievances some of them are and I think
one of the problems with the refugee
grievance is that it's been inflated
there there are seven times more refugee
now after 70 plus years than they were
at the time of this war and one reason
for that is that there's a politicized
way in which they're defined you could
be a pal you can be a citizen of Jordan
who is fully resettled in Jordan and yet
be counted as a refugee and you can be a
refugee who's in a refugee camp so
there's something really wrong with the
way that's accounted for and so I think
the politicization of that grievance
makes it really hard to untangle and the
worst part is that the Palestinian
movement this is uniform including the
supposed moderates they hold that it's
an absolute wholesale right of return so
so basically six million people have to
come back into Israel now that is a
there's something really fishy about
that I think you have to agree and
that's not a grievance that I think you
can easily remedy because you have to
really think about what happened in the
history and figure out the culpability
of all parties not just Israel which is
usually the one who's painted as the
villager
do you want to come in China yeah so I
think it's important that we note that
largely the reason there are so many
more Palestinians seven times as many
refugees mostly towards a natural high
birth rate and what's what's not
mentioned is that there were plans in
place by the Israeli military or the
nascent Israeli military to conduct
ethnic cleansing in Palestine in 1948
the most esteemed Israeli historians
like Benny Morris admitted this David
ben-gurion has admitted to it he's been
on the record I can read quotes that
this was a historical crime it pales in
comparison to the Holocaust at any time
that people try to equate them I think
they're wrong but it doesn't deny that
there was truly a grievance there and
also yes many of them may have become
out of necessity citizens of Jordan but
I would imagine that people who left
Poland in response to the World War two
though they quickly became citizens the
United States if they could would still
consider themselves refugees from Poland
now as for rights of return I think it's
very interesting first of all I don't
think that six million people can
actually come into Israel that's going
to have to be arbitrated with a symbolic
right of return and compensation it's
just it's not possible for Jewish to
remain both democratic and
Jewish while letting six million
Palestinians and I recognize that but
you know who does have a right of return
based on religion Israel a right of
return for any Jew worldwide so what I'm
interested in is why does that right
which is based purely on religion
ethnicity why does that exist but the
right for Palestinians whose
grandparents were you know kicked out of
their villages should be so easily
dismissed I think it's a it's a
fascinating dichotomy and it's
problematic we're coming to yeah I'm
glad you raised that because the right
of return is Israel's immigration law
that permits as you said instant or
almost instant citizenship to Jews I
think that's a real problem I don't
think we can treat that as the principle
by which to to hold both sides
accountable to cuz I a lot of countries
have that kind of rule but I think it's
a problem I think it reflects the the
motivations for establishing Israel but
I think just a couple of Corrections on
some of the things you said Benny Morris
does not think as far as I read him that
there was a premeditated plan to cleanse
the land
I think he's written on the contrary
that that's the opposite and in fact the
evidence and I think it's worth reading
other historians to that part of what
happened there was a lot of people who
left as a consequence of the war and it
was military contingencies that led to
them being - fleeing now the high number
of refugees is not exclusively birth
rate related it is the fact that unique
among all refugees in history that we
know of they're defined as you can be a
refugee through your father's bloodline
so if you're born to someone as a
refugee even if you are not born present
in that place where the war happened
you're a refugee so are your children
through the male line that's not the
same standard that the UN High
Commission for Refugees for other
conflicts holds so part of the issue is
it's a politicized definition of
refugees now I want to just acknowledge
that there are refugees who were invited
to come back and resettled and that's
definitely a fact but I don't think
either side should be held to this idea
that it's Israel has a right of return
and and
that's what we should hold it because I
think that's a problematic rule and I
don't think it's easy to say what
Israel's immigration rules should be but
I don't think those are very different
things in understanding this issue yeah
okay and then also I know we have people
in the audience want to ask questions do
you do you guys want to wait for
audience questions what do you have any
questions you want to ask the other yeah
yeah Danny what what do you take to be
the basis for Israel's right to exist
well that's an interesting point because
one could argue that it's a problematic
framing for any state to have the right
to exist I think that the the historical
wrong against the Jewish people which is
unique to a certain degree especially in
the aftermath of the Holocaust meant
that there was a global need an
understanding among the states of the
post-world War two world that there was
a special situation and thus Israel
should have a right to a sovereign
Jewish state which is why there was a UN
Commission which is why there was a
partition which even though Arabs were
still the majority gave 55 percent of
the land to Israel this was problematic
for a number of reasons since Israelis
or Jews only owned 7 percent of the
property at that time but I do think
that the special circumstances of the
Jewish people made it a global norm and
accepted global norm by most states that
later form the UN - to have an Israeli
state now I will admit that there are
intellectual arguments against any state
having the right to exist
I choose on my own to accept the Israeli
right to exist because of the historic
wrongs done to the Jewish people you
have a question to ask you know I don't
do you want to yeah I'm the microphone
microphone please so Ilana would you
please define what you mean by the quote
defeat of the Palestinian movement how
do you see this proceeding and how long
will it take
sure so I think it's a multi generation
process it doesn't happen overnight
it requires the kind of shift that
happened off to World War two with
the Nazi regime in Germany and with
Japan and essentially what it requires I
don't think it requires necessarily a
large-scale conflict that's armed and
violent but I think it requires a
psychological shift the abandonment of a
goal that is animating the hostilities
on one side and in my analysis the
Palestinian movement is animated by a
goal of making the whole of the
territory that is now Israel ruled by
Palestinians and that means from the
River Jordan to the Mediterranean that's
the phrasing that's commonly used and I
think the achievement of that requires
sustained pressure and communicating
that violence is not going to pay which
is the way in which the negotiations
which you're you seem to be an advocate
for really encourage so the the the
peace process model was we talked with
anybody we may we pretend that the
Palestinian movement was deal with and
that they were moderating and we sat
down with them numerous times we meaning
the Israelis and then led and sponsored
by the US on the premise that you should
speak to anyone and I think that is
empirically false what that led to is
they were given the encouragement to
think that wow we spent decades
attacking Israel we didn't get as far as
we wanted but hey we just got invited to
the diplomatic negotiations look at the
the way in which we've been elevated and
given a dignity we've never earned
Arafat was a pioneer of international
terrorism and violence I mean that I
think cannot be disputed and here he was
celebrated as somebody who you know he's
given that up well has he has he really
so I think that was a misconception and
in fact what those kinds of negotiations
led to was no is a rewarding of that
kind of behavior and a continuation and
enough funding of it over time so I
think what you want to do is reverse
that so defeat means not rewarding that
behavior but showing that the more you
do that kind of thing the more you
attack the less likely you are to ever
to reach your goal and it's it's a lost
goal so it's a long-term process it
requires shifting
the understanding of what's achievable
and that requires significant pressure
over time so so you do you believe that
they can be militarily defeated the
Palestinian movement and and let me just
say quickly cuz it seems like you're
saying Palestinians have to wait more
multi-generations I mean it's been three
or four generations so now we're saying
it's gonna be multi-generational to
defeat them so now a Palestinian refugee
might have to wait seven or eight
generations but Japan as you mentioned
got its sovereignty back in 1952 despite
attacking Pearl Harbor and West Germany
got its sovereignty back in 1954 and was
armed and was given tanks and was put
into NATO by 1954 so it only had to go
through nine years of occupation prior
to regaining its sovereignty so I I'm
wondering if you really believe that
there is a military solution to the
Palestinian resistance I think that can
be I don't think it has to be military
but I think the the premise of your
question is what I think is essential to
challenge and I want to raise that which
is you are you seem to be operating on
the premise that the Palestinians are
entitled to a state and you're
challenging me for saying they don't and
you're that's part of your argument that
I'm being one-sided well let me make it
explicit I don't think the right to
self-determination can mean that you are
entitled to create your own tyranny and
then sell yourself and the people that
you regard as part of your group into
slavery or into domination and
authoritarianism there's no such right
and so long as that is what's animating
the Palestinian movement they should not
be pursuing they should not be permitted
to pursue a state now if there's a point
at which in the future that is no longer
the kind of state that they're working
to build then fine I'm the only favorite
the standard is you in order to to be
justified in pursuing that the momentous
step of creating a state which means you
have the monopoly on the use of force
within a geographical area that's a
momentous step the only my view the only
basis for that is you're actually going
to create a state that protects freedom
and or you're leaving a situation which
you don't have freedom you're moving
towards a situation with greater freedom
is my view of sort of the essential
premise for Israel's basses it's
basically free society if Palestinians
really wanted that and there was
evidence for that then I would be in
favor of it I would say yes go ahead
build yourself a state create it support
it I'm not opposed to that what I'm
opposed to the Palestinians demanding
and the idea that democracy is the
all-purpose solvent for making
everything good because people enough
people voted for it which is completely
wrong if that's the principle then yeah
they should have a state but that's not
the principle it has to be that you're
the only way in which you can make sense
of self-determination for a group of
people is they're trying to reach
freedom and that's not what the
Palestinian movement has been pursuing
now we can talk about the situation in
which they live in today which is really
parlous and difficult but I don't think
there's evidence to think there's
certainly no evidence that they've given
us that what they're trying to do is
move towards greater freedom and that's
what that's the basis of my objection
and so the issue of how long do they
have to wait they have to wait until
they change their mind about what kind
of society they want to build Japan
abandon its goals after World War two
with great deal of pressure as you know
from probably from studying this and
Germany was defeated both of those were
defeated in there in I think those are
outstanding examples in history because
it was so rapid and the fact that the
military defeat came first and what
happened in Iraq which I believe you saw
firsthand I don't believe the surge and
that whole thing of handing out money
really is a solution and yeah so so that
did not work and I think we saw that
with the rise of Isis which is I think
of fruit of that attempt to solve Iraq
by dealing with everybody so the the
issue is not how long they have to wait
it's what is the goal and what is the
standard by which you judge it well I do
have a comment about that which again it
feels like the Palestinians are being
held to a different standard than the
Israelis who is to determine what the
people want except for the people
themselves through democracy I agree
that democracy is flawed but as
Churchill said it's the worst solution
except for all the others potentially in
your books or you said that you believe
that Palestinian grievances quote cannot
explain let alone
defy the armed struggle of the
Palestinians but article 51 of the UN
Charter recognizes quote the inherent
right of individual or collective
self-defense and the protocol one
addition to the Geneva Conventions
explicitly recognizes armed conflicts in
which people are fighting against alien
occupation so I mean one could argue
that because the Palestinians are still
in a state of resistance still in a
state of insurgency that you know we've
never really seen what a Palestinian
state would look like we've only seen
the state lit of a collaboration as the
regime that really looks like Swiss
cheese because though the Israelis have
pulled settlements out of Gaza which
were minimal to begin with and pulled
the furthest outpost out of the West
Bank nothing has been done about the
five hundred thousand Jewish Israeli
settlers in the West Bank which have
turned if you've seen a map of the West
Bank it looks like a piece of Swiss
cheese rather delicious quite frankly I
mean it's a problem when they are coming
to questions so III have a real
objection to the idea that there's a two
different standards here I think there
is one standard and that is are you
living up to are you trying to achieve a
free society and I think democracy is
not the standard democracy is a tool is
a subordinate part of what makes of
society free it's an it's an essential
part of it but it is not what makes
something good or right just because
people vote for it now the issue is the
the issue that you're raising here which
is you're invoking international
treaties and laws and this whole regime
of armed resistance and so forth I
question that I'm not entirely convinced
that that into kind of hundred and
eighty countries be wrong yeah they can
be wrong the question is is this a moral
principle and I go further than that
because I'm I should make my I put a
cards on the table I am NOT a fan of the
UN I am I think there are serious
problems with the customary so-called
laws of war and including the moral
premises that govern the conduct of war
I think morality is essential in conduct
of
having standards for what you do in the
battlefield but I think there are real
problems with the standards that are
imposed because they disadvantage those
who obey them and they empower those who
disobey them so this is the clear
problem with that and the idea that we
treat UN bodies or international law as
essentially like a papal pronouncement
that it's unquestionable I think that's
a mistake you have to really think about
is this right or not and you you can
make an argument that the Palestinians
are trying to resist occupation and I'm
sure they hate being on the under
occupation a lot of them being told that
this is all Israel's fault the question
however is what is their life being like
during occupation I I'm sure none nobody
in this room would choose to live under
occupation but did you know and this is
relevant and I'm sure this has come up
in your reading of this is that however
bad you might think or the occupation
actually has been the material
measurements of life for Palestinians
are better twenty years into the
occupation than they were before into
the life expectancy infant mortality the
hookups to electricity were like that
eight percent there were ninety percent
within fifteen years now you might say
yeah screw it I still hate the Israelis
that's fine but you if you're talking
about individual human beings and the
the welfare that they need to live then
you can't argue that they're not
materially better off under occupation
even if they still a dream of a
Palestinian state so the question is are
they seeking freedom and a better life
and that to me is the standard by which
we have to evaluate these things got a
chance respond but
you might want to fit in your mouth to
that question the first question please
phrase your question as a question if
you could well I'd like to thank the
major Danny for his service and
hopefully he'll on has that dual
citizenship this work well for you it's
hard to believe I'm old enough to be
both of your grandfather's
but IIIi try yes grandpa yeah I I was
brought up with with the fact that boys
or was the bankers was bankers worse and
and at the same time I was always taught
to follow the money and so it's not a
mistake that Arafat Yasser Arafat he
left how many years over over ten years
ago with if you you know he was killed
on the you know special circumstances
but family has billions and I don't know
how how what's your question my question
is how do you expect to end a
complication that exists right now
especially when the the Arabs who are
really the Palestinians I don't know
where Palestine came from it's not
mentioned anywhere what is your question
my question is how how are you going to
end a conflict that exists right now if
what's behind the behind the conflict is
something that really is is that what we
could put our fingers off one thing if
the question is about economic
conditions that the Palestinian
leadership have enjoyed there is a
difference if she's worth noting that
the PLO of which are FL is the leader
and then Mahmoud Abbas they're much more
in the model of the kind of secular Arab
dictator who not only dominates his
people but also exploits them
economically so there's definitely a
great deal of documented graft and
racketeering under the Palestinian
Authority what the difference is the
Hamas and this is this speaks to its
ideological character one of the ways in
which is gained support and credibility
is that it's seen as uncorruptible
precisely because it's religious I mean
it the way it gets funding is not from
outside regimes according to its
propaganda it gets its money from Akkad
which is a kind of tie the religious
tide now the reality is Hamas does get
outside funding but the essential issue
is that the PLO is much more in the
model of exploiting its people
economically as well and the Hamas is
definitely it makes a point of not doing
that explicitly because that
part of its prestige how do you want
America but absolutely I don't think
that the conflict will and anytime soon
I don't think there will be a military
defeat my opponent keeps talking about
how the only time you have a right to a
state is if it's in favor of freedom and
the word freedom and freedom and I think
it's an excellent word but what we don't
have for the Palestinians is any freedom
to form its own sovereign state
they've never had that at any point
Jordan is not same as Palestinians as
excuse me you if you want to ask a
question question is civil that rude and
you know it's the intellectual as for
the economy it is true that the economy
of the occupied territories grew very
rapidly specific in the 1970s but this
was only tying the Palestinian economy
to Israel's whims and it was never
accompanied by you know any major
internal development as its own society
so one major economic report noted quote
the growth witnessed in the territories
is fundamentally not just not
sustainable and ending the occupation is
the prerequisite for transforming the
territory's economic potential into
reality just two brief comments so you
know in my book what I argue is that the
Palestinians have not had the full
expression of a state with full
sovereignty that's certainly true I
agree with that but what you can measure
is to the extent that they've achieved
some measure of self-rule some sell
degree of governance self-governance you
can see that in several places the
Palestinian authorities the most recent
in 1994 to the present the Gaza Strip
from which Israel withdrew every last
person and left it to the Palestinians
so there's no occupation left there and
you can see it as well in when the PLO
set up bases on the border with Jordan
and when it later set up bases under the
within the Palestinian refugee camps in
Lebanon in all those cases there's
commonalities in terms of the way they
governed which was authoritarian and in
it was they had the practice of full
control and arbitrary courts and and
just the kind of things that you don't
want to see and then this gate got full
expression under the pool full of
expression under the Palestinian
Authority which is a step
a full state so look if yeah I get what
you're saying Danny do you want the
Palestinians to have the room to create
the kind of state that you think they
should have but I'd love to know what is
the evidence for thinking that it would
be anything better than and in fact not
worse than what we see in the
Palestinian Authority today and and in
Gaza because where do you see the
evidence for that of course you know
what's really important we don't have
the evidence for that because there has
been no sovereignty for the Palestinians
in anything except a state lit that
looks like Swiss cheese that is
essentially a collaboration as the
regime with the Israeli authorities
Palestinians have as much sovereignty as
their masters give them and their
masters are the ones with the American
weapons and with the American money the
reality is they cannot militarily defeat
Israel but Israel cannot military defeat
them we don't know what real Palestinian
sovereignty would look like because it
has not existed since 1948
we have questions questions of the oil
go ahead please ask a question hello my
questions to Ilan you bathe a lot of for
your argument about defeating the
movement in the fact that Hamas wants to
eliminate is Israel that's what you says
but in American law if someone wants to
kill me doesn't give me the right to
kill a person so why do you think
Americans should support that defeat the
question I get it what we're dealing
with is a situation that's not governed
by American law and the principle is not
you have a right to kill the person
attacking you you have a right to defend
yourself that's the principle now what
I'm arguing for and I argue for it in
more detail in the book than I do here
is that to understand what Hamas is
about and what the Palestinian movement
has been doing since it came to the fore
is it's a sustained campaign over time
with that animating goal now are they
militarily in a position to destroy
Israel I don't think they are but they
would like to be and they've they've
shown with their numerous attacks that
that's what they're after into
essentially psychologically destroy
Israel by
terrorizing and that's the goal my
argument is Israel has a right to
self-defense now because this is a
long-standing war I think the way out of
this conflict and I think it is solvable
is if you give them to believe through
action that their goal is unachievable
and you can do that wars have ended
because one side has given up its goal
and being led to believe that this is
hopeless and I think that the idea that
that's fantasy is ignoring the fact that
we've seen this in other contexts I mean
World War two ended not because we
negotiated with the Nazis we could
defeated them world world and we
defeated the the Japanese now there's
certainly a great deal of reluctance to
fight and defeat people I mean Obama
said he doesn't like to use the word
victory and Danny certainly doesn't
think that's achievable and I agree Iraq
was a no way in war but it is not
because we fought to win it's because we
didn't fight to win and I think it's
many things to say about that and I'm
sorry that you had to suffer some of the
consequences of that now that's what I
said I mean I've been arguing about the
failure of American foreign policy in
the Middle East for a long time and I
think it's a misconception to think
Yukon and Wars through defeat I can
assure you that I fought to win the
reality the reality is there was no
victory over the Iraqi people so long as
we tried to create a country in our own
image the reality was we violated Iraqi
sovereignty and so long as we did so
there would be a forever insurgency
correct World War two ended but it was a
conventional war declared between powers
but every one of those countries
involved in World War two that held
colonies every one of them lost those
colonies to much less technologically
advanced militaries because national
movements do not easily die question
next question yeah I I don't have time
to I challenge your your understanding
so as you who's you who to suggestion to
Ilan to you I challenged your
understanding of the Palestinian
Authority I've been there a lot and I've
studied it a lot and it's not like the
Nazis and it's not like the
and and it doesn't have to be defeated
in the same way but my bigger question
is about the two-state solution beyond
without a two-state solution you have
two choices you either have up basically
what's close to a power tie to stateless
people or you have a single entity which
would mean there would be no Jewish
stage and and so there's really no other
solution that is that all satisfactory
to people you either believe in a idea
of a Jewish state want one or who
believe in democracy and do not want a
revival of of the evils that we've
already seen with in South Africa and
other places okay you get your question
that's a question addressed to you I
guess you you I think it's relevant to
think about what it means for there to
be an end to this conflict and I don't
think it's you start with well what does
the configuration of the society look
like I think you have to start with what
is the what is driving the conflict and
how do you end it and then there are
going to be questions about what happens
then what kind of society should there
be once the Palestinian movement is no
longer seeking to liquidate its opponent
Israel and I think they're real hard
questions I agree we certainly don't
want a whole population that is denied
citizenship I think the Israelis
certainly won't accept being a minority
I think they're fearful of that and I
think for a number of good historical
reasons they're fearful of being a
minority in their own country I don't
think that's an easy problem to solve
I mean but I think what you what I think
it's a mistake to turn that around and
say well the obvious solution is they
gotta have to be two states I don't
think that's obvious and I don't think
it's the way to begin I think the way to
begin is to say why is this been going
on for so long and why what's driving it
what are the ideas going on here and
then what is the principle that should
govern it can we consider I mean I want
to say something what can we expect from
a Palestinian state and it's I don't
think it's true that we don't know I
think we have a lot of empirical
evidence of what the ideas of the
Palestine movement
in practice and I think it's also
telling if you look at the the
scholarship of Rashid Khalidi who is a
Palestinian scholar he is a Columbia he
wrote a book about that why the
Palestinian movement has failed in its
attempt as a state building and one of
the things that struck me in reading
this is that he says sort of he doesn't
take it as seriously as I do what he
says in passing look they they have
given so little thought to what it would
look like to achieve a state that is
alarming and to me that is well it's not
only alarming it's suspicious because if
you spent decades yearning for
sovereignty wouldn't you give it a lot
more thought about what it would
actually look like wouldn't you
promulgate what that actually looks like
and I think the the absence of doing
that speaks to this is not a sincere
effort at righting wrongs or serving a
Palestinian people who some of whom have
suffered severely so I think there's a
lot of things to solve once you get past
moving the obstacles in the road and
some of those are really hard things to
solve and I think you've hit on one of
those all right we have unfortunately we
have time for only one final question
before we go to the summations so please
ask your question yeah I guess there's a
more philosophical question both to both
groups here I'm unclear whether the
arguments are deontological or
consequentialist so as far as Elon is
concerned you've you made a moral
presumption and maybe I'm asking this as
being a different kind of libertarian
that freedom is somehow tied to
democracy individuality and secularism
and therefore have rigged the debate off
for the side of Israel and on the side
of Danny it's unclear to me whether
you're arguing for the feasibility or
the desirability because your arguments
have been for the desirability of
collaborating with with the movement the
Palestinian movement but you haven't
really demonstrated the feasibility
because the question is what if it is
impossible to both have a Jewish state
and to collaborate with them would you
then take a deontological position say
no we still have to collaborate or a
consequentialist one and say well maybe
we have to do something else and if so
what would it be
when you go first standing on this one
yeah I think that a Palestinian state is
desirable it is not currently feasible
so long as there are Jewish only Rhodes
Jewish only settlements five hundred
thousand Israelis in the West Bank Gaza
shut off from both the sea and the land
that's the most heavily densely
populated place on the earth half the
people get their goods from United
Nations Organization so I I think yes it
is as it stands relatively infeasible
for there to be a Palestinian state but
largely I would argue that is due to the
intransigence of Israeli policy and
self-defeating violence on the behalf of
terrorist elements within the
Palestinians and I agree with Rashid
Khalidi and it's interesting he brought
him up because he does critique
rightfully aspects of the PLO aspects of
the Palestinian Authority but what must
be remembered is he is one of the
preeminent historians in favour of
Palestinian nationalism in favor of a
Palestinian sovereign entity so I think
that in its current state it's not
feasible but through honest negotiations
or removal of the military occupation
and a removal of the settlements it is
possible one second extra minute on your
summation and so we want to go to the
summations and you can answer that
question and take the podium okay
so I'll try to summation give you my
summation and I'll try to address that
question you raise loss I'm an atheist
I'm an individualist I'm an advocate of
liberty and I believe that liberty or
the principle of freedom has to be the
framework by which to understand the
claims in this conflict and the
character of the adversaries I don't
accept that we have no basis for
thinking that apalis what a Palestinian
state would look like I think we have a
great deal of evidence to know what to
expect and I think it's the
responsibility of anyone who's
advocating for that as an outcome anyone
who's in favor of a Palestinian state in
the present to make the case that it
would be a moral state meaning it would
be it would protect the lives and
freedom of Palestinians and do so more
so than ever in the past and that it's
meeting that standard I don't think
anyone has put forward that basis that
evidence and I think it's it's a Dodge
and unfortunately I think there's a
great deal of evidence that that's
dodging to say we don't know what it
would look like it's a problem that we
don't know what it would look like and
there's been enough development in
political thought over the last 200
years for people to pick up say the
Federalist Papers to pick up a used
Constitution and learn something from it
and say look this is the sort of thing
we're thinking of doing what do you
think of that is does that make sense to
you we can make a case that this is what
we're doing but just to say we're a
group we deserve a state and you're
you're not letting us have it and we're
going to rage against that that is not
an argument that deserves credibility
and let me add that there are many more
historical issues that have been raised
that we didn't get a chance to answer
and claims that my opponent has raised
that I haven't had a chance to some of
them are addressed in the book and I
encourage you to look at that the issue
that I want to stress is that the
Palestinian movement does exist it's a
real thing they think of themselves as a
movement even if the
opponent tonight says that I'm I'm
simplifying it there is a progression
that you can track over time and what
maybe maybe it's difficult to
conceptualize but what what brings it
together what coheres in this movement
it's the goal of a state in place of
Israel and that state is what defines
that state is some sort of authoritarian
or theocratic type model of we see
plenty of in the Middle East and that's
the unity of this movement even if the
the justifications for it over time went
from Arab nationalism Palestinian
nationalism and now it's more framed in
Islamist terms but that's the unifying
threads with through time I haven't made
the case and I'm sorry if you've been
led to believe this I haven't made the
case that Israel is blameless or that it
is somehow a saint that is certainly not
the view I opened with and it's still
not my view and it's certainly not the
view you'll find in my book I castigate
Israel from many of its flaws and there
more that we can talk about I think it's
a mistake to present the the major
obstacle being Israel even if it's made
even if it's not being entirely fair
here and has committed wrongs the over
time the pattern is that Israel is
responding to aggression that is and
this significant reason to believe is
seeking to do significant damage to life
and property and in response to that I
think it's being justified in
retaliating against them if it's going
beyond that then it's wrong and that's
the standard that I apply here and I
think what's missing is I I think what
the the silence that I I'm glad was
partially broken tonight but not
completely is you have a judge a moon
not only by its ideas and its Charter
and it's its founding documents but also
by its actions and I agree with that and
I think that the the issue here tonight
is the Palestinian movement has been
true to its ideas and we have to take
seriously what those ideas
and pretending that they're not there or
trying to whitewash them or say well
let's just bite our tongue and we have
to talk to anybody I think that misses
the point and it is significant that the
Palestinian issue has become not only as
llama sized in the sense that the
leading faction of Hamas is it's acting
on the idea of ideas of an Islamic
society that's what it seeks to do but
that it is aligned with other forces in
the region principally Iran and Qatar
that are supporting this idea and I
suggest that in this sense the conflict
is now really it's stark it's in terms
of the ideas do you believe that it's
better to have a free society or do you
believe in tyranny
whether it's nationalist or theocratic
and that to me is the question thank you
[Laughter]
why am I here tonight taking the
position in favor of a Palestinian state
by any logical measure with Islamist
organizations in both Iraq and
Afghanistan taking the lives of so many
of those who I'd loved one would think
that I would take the position of many
of my less educated soldiers which was
to hate Islam okay to hate Arabs in the
case of Iraq but I came to a place of
respect for the vast majority of the
people in the Middle East and I realized
that there were both strategic and
ethical reasons to care for both sides
in this conflict and thus I applied it
to the israel-palestine conflict I've
hoped to illustrate not a pro
Palestinian position tonight but a
middle road one that recognizes the
strengths of Israeli democracy at times
and also recognizes the plight of the
Palestinians I do think you've heard
another approach that's rather biased
that lambaste the very notion that
Palestinian has a movement have any
meaningful grievances or right to
self-defense there's something else and
it's a rather personal matter but it's
an essential one nonetheless it applies
to my third assertion that Israeli
policy MA
carry some blame for the intractability
of the conflict israel is not alone in
carrying some of that blame additionally
the United States must recognize its own
complicity and hindering peace virulent
hatred for the US for is for Israel and
Islamist terror plots in the West will
not meaningfully decrease until
Washington at least begins to address
the roots of the problem and rebalance
its one-sided relationship with Israel
first off it's the right thing to do
second it's a pivot away from these more
unhinged policies will actually make
American soldiers Israeli soldiers and
civilians in both societies Israel
United States ultimately safer to wit
this army officer whose interpreter from
Iraq Akil from Sadr City is here tonight
we heard earful about Israel policy
about America support for Israel from
angry moderates moderates mind you
around the middle of the road in Iraqi
society in both Iraq and Afghanistan
decorating dingy Baghdad apartments and
Kandahar hobbles with pictures of the
Dome of the rock in Jerusalem was quite
common these people cared about average
Palestinians even former CIA director
and General Petraeus not exactly a
liberal snowflake recognized this way
back in 2010 when he said that US
favoritism towards Israel in dangers his
troops he was predictably lambasted by
certain lobbying groups but that didn't
make him wrong if you want to genuinely
protect the homeland and the troops and
the Israeli troops from Islamist
inspired violence then insist that both
Washington and Israel demonstrate some
sense of equity and justice in Israel
Palestine that's what's missing from the
other argument tonight compromise is the
only way to peace it was the case in
Northern Ireland it was the case in
almost every anti-colonial movement
framing one side Israel in this case is
the protagonist will gain us nothing
besides the further alien ization and
radicalization of a new generation of
aggrieved Palestinians for compromise
requires personal humility and
self-awareness from both sides the
Palestinian movement must swear off
counterproductive and despicable terror
attacks on civilians and Israel must
measure its own violent attacks with the
required degree
proportionality and care for its usual
victims which are not Israeli civilians
but Palestinian non-combatants
statistically all serious Arab groups
Hamas included must accept the existence
of Israel and a two-state solution this
may sound like a tall order but notice
how unlike my opponents affirmation of
the resolution it recognizes the guilt
and responsibilities of both sides
it recognizes the notion of sovereignty
for both sides
my opponent loves the State of Israel it
it honestly bleeds through as an
admirable quality in his every word but
he's missing the fact that just liking
Israel's democracy more than the secular
Arab regimes or the Islamist Irish
regimes does not make it any more likely
they'll be amoled military or political
victory coming in the occupied
territories me I'm through with such
fanciful make-believe it died with a to
my own soldiers in Baghdad in Kandahar
Israel can no more defeat the narrowly
defined Palestinian movement and the
massive American military machine could
win any sort of military victory in Iraq
or Afghanistan now is the time for
realism not fantasy Israel must engage
Palestinian groups and negotiate
whatever your personal beliefs loyalties
or inclinations I ask that you show the
rationality and intellectual honesty to
vote in the negative and reject this
resolution to do so does not reject
Israel its people its existence or its
right to security it merely recognizes
there are two sides in this tale of woe
that there may just maybe still a middle
path to peace that involves a two-state
solution reject this resolution because
you have heads and hearts and you know
there's no other rational way thank you
thank thank you to you both and we are
now going to do the final voting Yvonne
is going to be signing books afterwards
he'll be at that table and it can chat
with you and Danny you please stick
around as well because a lot of people
will want to chat next next a month
we're going to be debating the issue of
climate change hope you can make it in
in in August were going to be debating
Bitcoin once again that event has had
the previous debate on Bitcoin had four
hundred fifty thousand views on YouTube
and was sold out weeks in advance you
may want to buy tickets to that event in
August I'm going to be once again
debating socialism in November against a
this time somebody who is sort of my own
size eight and an emeritus professor
named Richard Wolfe from University of
Massachusetts debating the broad issue
of socialism that will probably not be
at this all because we usually get
hopefully a lot of socials to show up
and we had we sold nearly 500 tickets to
the last social sebade I held with Basco
Sankara who I gather is gracing the
pages of New York magazine did not
listen to me when I told him you could
start the socialist resident revolution
right now just put some of the money
together it could happen he's preferred
to go the intellectual route and I'm not
surprised that he did that Jane where do
we stand on the voting when women on the
voting again I want to thank my wife
who's Kay to this affair and thanks
c-span c-span is filmed this and so up
you will be on c-span
and it will also be shown on video by
reason and will be available on our
website in in May we're going to be
debating vegetarianism the and so a real
food fight in May first is the rather
tame debate we had this evening and and
again I I do want to we were a little
bit nervous about the the the import of
this debate and I want to commend you
all and commend our our speakers our
debaters especially on the stability
that they felt toward each other yeah
yes well they well they were and in fact
usually usually this hugging but if you
guys want to just want to shake it we
have it no how can you okay okay okay
the okay the the voting went this way
the the yes vote for the resolution was
27.2% and the yes vote picked up nine
points went to 36% so that nine points
was the figure to beat the no vote went
from 33 percent to fifteen fifty percent
picked up 14 points so the no vote wins
the Tootsie Roll a congratulation to you
both
you